okay so today we're starting a new
medieval thinker who's not that distant
from Saotome
remember we jumped ahead about a
thousand years from Epictetus to an
Somme and now we're sort of slowing it
down a little bit this is in the Middle
Ages
st. Anselm was sort of at the very end
and look what some people call the Dark
Ages and now we're into the High Middle
Ages and now we're talking about this
guy Thomas Aquinas
and Thomas was a Dominican friar the
Dominicans were one of those religious
orders that that gets in the High Middle
Ages like the Franciscans and so he's
kind of like handsome right he's
handsome as a monk
this guy's a friar Thomas actually
taught at the University of Paris first
he studied there and then he became a
teacher and I'll tell you just a little
bit about it and then we'll go into some
of his his philosophical ideas but
actually before we do the philosophical
ideas I mean you know there's one of
these polling things and getting getting
some discussion doing but so first
Thomas should I tell you about him first
they call them the dumb ox when he was
in school he was a big fat guy he made
advances or glandular problem or
something like that big boned right and
he didn't talk of awful lot and most of
his other fellow students thought he was
actually pretty stupid it turned out
that he wasn't he turned out to be one
of the most brilliant philosophers or
God
he just didn't talk an awful lot and
kept things to himself well he was
learning some of you may relate to that
right if you're sort of a quiet
disposition his teacher Albert the Great
said that ox will one day let out
a roar that will shake all of
Christendom
and Thomas eventually became one of the
most important Christian thinkers of all
time
what he did that was really unique at
least at that time he wasn't the only
person his teachers do well Thomas did
it in a much better way was to bring
together new sort of synthesis
philosophy and church doctrine and
philosophy was undergoing a kind of
revolution at that time they have lost
most in the West they had lost most of
Aristotle's books as a matter of fact if
you look at a reading list that we have
from these monasteries there's a lot of
literature that they had just lost for a
long time and luckily had been preserved
somewhere else you know in some of the
Middle Ages it was actually Irish monks
who preserve some literature and then it
goes through the rest of Europe after
the Dark Ages are coming to an end when
it came to Aristotle Aristotle's texts
have been preserved by the Arabs and the
Arabs were still in Spain at that time
Spain was still a Muslim area and they
had these these Greek tax from Aristotle
that were being translated first into
Latin and then they finally got my hands
on the Greek and Aristotle was sort of a
lightning bolt to them because Aristotle
is like taking a car that's you know got
an OK engine it's on a sports car or
something like that and then suddenly
dropping in the the engine of a sports
car into it
supercharged you know goes a lot faster
got a lot more power that's the way
Aristotle's philosophy was because
Aristotle was so systematic and one of
the things that was different about
Aristotle was he focused very much on
the world of experience but we could see
here since reason about by pointing at
and not a lot of the other philosophers
have done that another way that you
could think about this is that Thomas is
bringing together reason and faith you
know we tend quite often to think of
religious faith as if it's something
wholly irrational right if you ask most
people out on the street who will in
general in this country they say they
believe in God right if you poll most
people in the United States the majority
of them said we can got and then you ask
them why do you believe it or can you
prove it or something like that
a lot of them say you know I just sort
of take it on faith I just believe it I
don't know why I believe it or sometimes
they'll get angry at you too who are you
to question me and times 80 is get angry
too
I'll tell you a story about that if we
have time with that kind of funny good
reason and faith through co-exist does
being religious make you less of a
thinker
that's something we're thinking about
does it just it just mean say turning
reason on that's the way some people
think about it actually there's some
religious people who think about it that
way they they say that faith is
something that you know much higher than
reason reason can never understand it so
good thinking about stuff and then
you'll actually get it right there so
more mystics or something for what we
call fides who have that sort of view
Thomas didn't have that view he thought
that faith and reason sort of fused
together and he thought this because of
his views on what God is and is
beautiful
and beings if you think about the
philosophers that we studied so far how
did they do reason in relation to the
human being reason is part of us right
where does it fit is it like you know on
top is it on the bottom where do you put
it what else is in the human being we've
done a lot of talking about this in the
semester what else do you do you have in
you besides a faculty of reason not
logical all the time are you I'm not
we'll see you
and give you again weather why the
uncomfortable silence what everybody
feeling right now anybody it's a Ford if
you want I'm okay with that maybe it is
born why are you thinking about
something else outside of class that
you're anxious about a lot of your six
that you probably know probably just
lethargic and would rather be home in
bed right you'd rather be home in bed
you remember what we call that sort of
thing
source of the D desire right reason is
something that your desires are also in
us
your emotions are you right that's
that's a huge part of you you wouldn't
want to just be all reason no emotions I
certainly wouldn't want you to be all
views and mental functions you have
these appetites will we talk about all
these different things so throw all
these things together in a big pot and
call it you know mister so-and-so it is
so and so where does reason go does it
does it sink to the bottom or is it
float to the top goes to the top right
and reason is the one that can kind of
decide what everything else should do
it's the one that actually you know
reason can understand your emotions can
your emotions actually understand reason
aerosols got this great line about anger
recess anger is like an over a hasty
servant you all you've all been at
restaurant where the waiter the waitress
is paying attention to you but not that
much and you say I would like and
they're off you off trying to get you
something they've ever been in the case
like that and then they bring you the
wrong thing you know you could wait it
till I finish saying something and then
you'd know what I wanted that's the way
air assault says anger is anger
perceives that your honor and then it
starts reasoning out it says I've been
wronged
I better knock that person out now Jones
feel right to that
castigate that pick whatever you want I
should punish them emotions don't really
understand reason although they have
their own sort of structure reason it
can understand emotions what about
things of faith the effect well Thomas
thought that reason human reason given
to us by God so that we can understand
everything so that we can use it
somebody who's saying just read the
Bible and you're going to be okay and
don't think about it that would be
totally alien to Thomas Aquinas he would
say that person doesn't actually
understand the very religion that
they're talking about because they don't
understand that human beings were
created as rational creatures so this
can lead us into this discussion about
arguments for God's existence but before
we go into that let's think about this a
little bit more like I did with singsong
I'm not going to ask I actually had
little no occurrence of use of secret
ballots with you guys but I forgot to
bring a note cards because I'm not going
to ask anybody haven't raised their
hands who believes and gatherer does in
class because it's kind of a touchy
personal issue right what I am getting
asking about is this let's say you
believe in God what grounds do you have
for believing in God but let's say you
don't believe in God why do you think
God doesn't this what what grounds do
you have for for saying or let's say you
know maybe some of you we call it
agnostic you haven't made up your minds
yet you're sometimes you think one day
it's this way the other day you think
it's that way where you say I just don't
know right what would it take yeah if I
was never presented with
idea all day God and I would never think
that one existed and I don't really
think that one says yeah that's an
interesting point that if you nobody had
brought forth an idea of God you don't
think that you and probably if you think
other people too right wouldn't have
sort of naturally come to that
conclusion and Thomas would actually be
kind of sympathetic to that oftentimes
we present these proofs as if you know
you got natural man walking around in
the jungle or you know on planes and
he's looking around he sees things and
then he says ah you know all these must
have you had cause we can't trace these
causes back all the way therefore there
must be a prime mover let's call that
guy and you know historically is that
the way things happen yeah so if that's
supposed to be a reconstruction of our
reasoning process that's very imaginary
that's almost like a cartoon rather than
the real thing
so Thomas isn't saying that because that
would have been you know kind of silly
to say even in Thomas's time that well
you just gotta look at this it's a
parentage and people struggle with it
throughout the millennium even even some
of the great you know religious fathers
went through their crises of faith
st. Augustine who you see Thomas talking
about you have these long periods of
doubts and he actually joined a
religious cult for a long time the
Manicheans before he got out of that
mother Teresa it was a little bit closer
at times cause his died recently
and if you remember what the huge news
was shortly after she died this is the
nun who was in Calcutta and she was
taking care of dying people for 50 years
she started an order of nuns just to
take care of the dying and you know that
seems like pretty nice thing to do and
these nuns would you know go to Mass
every day and all that does anyone
remember what the big bombshell shocker
was for this lady
she even lectured president
the invited her to the prayer dinner and
she didn't get invited back because she
and he came over he's you know doing his
typical Clinton thing you know
glad-handing everybody and you know and
she said you know why you've got so many
social problems cuz you kill all your
children she said it like that to him so
she's you know pretty straight talker
what turned out we found they found her
her Diaries how she died
she'd been living the last 50 years not
feeling the presence of forgot it's
really being healthy desert and still
carrying on what she thought she I'd be
doing sure she believed intellectually
that there was a God and that she had an
experience of it you know way back in
her youth and that she did the end that
experience again
the rest of her life and yet she stayed
true to it
that's guts you know that's that's a
that's pretty tough to do that be sort
of like falling in love with somebody at
your age you know a freshman year you
meet somebody in your philosophy class
you fall in love with them and they're
really great for that time and then they
go away on a trip you guys are planning
on getting married right they go away on
a trip and no letters no nothing and you
say I know that they're out there and
they involved me and you stick to it for
50 years until you die then we take some
determination wouldn't it Thomas didn't
have that sort of experience as a matter
of fact Thomas felt that he you know you
got intellectually
so let's look at some of the stuff that
that he says again though before that
what would it take for people to believe
that God exists here we get to you know
rounds for belief why do people say that
they think God exists there could be
some bad grounds think about people you
know people you run into could be the
the evangelist at the street corner
could be Uncle Joe you know who corners
you have the family Christmas wants it
now if you've met Jesus could be anybody
you like
could be somebody trying to convince you
God doesn't exist you know the Richard
Dawkins in the world why do people say
they think God exists in your experience
yeah okay so they first a desire I
believe and then maybe they say I got
believe in something it may as well be
God or I'm going to believe it's
something I'll believe it the biggest
thing I can and god is that then which
nothing greater can be thoughts kind of
about you know cart before the horse a
way of putting things together wasn't
but the people do do this and there are
philosophers who talk about like that
the will to believe in the need to
believe yeah feel like help them through
something problem in their life like
believing in God even people in jail
like you can relate just let people in
jail come religious because and they
want to have something to believe in
it's not terrible
yeah and there are religious communities
in the prisons and then you know they
could they can latch onto to that so hug
let's see how should we differentiate
that they find believing opening mindset
trying to satisfy some need that they
yeah okay okay that's what Thomas would
call the argument from Authority which
he calls the weakest already mental ball
so one so said so so it must be true
that's the reason a lot of people to
believe right before quite frankly
because everybody around them said
there's a God so they said it what what
else could maybe lead somebody's that
believing in God
yeah maybe like it's the for in some
sort of accident
[Music]
okay so now we're getting to something
that's a little bit personal experience
and you know they think there's a
miracle that took place and therefore
there must be God some people actually
think of like had a religious experience
where they saw God or so on angel or as
like that and some sometimes they're
people who really don't want to believe
and don't see any purpose in it and you
know they were taught to believe in God
that they rejected a long time ago they
say yeah this is sensation Keyes washed
over me or you know all sorts of things
along those lines so religious
experience could be a reason any other
reasons people might ask you let's
pacify me over convinced by the insults
argument that was about you know sort of
unpack a few of you said that yeah I
find an some convincing so I'm going to
zoom that there's at least some people
who are convinced by you get an idea and
you play around with the idea there you
go God exists
we give you no debate limits that's a
good way to do it or not bit that is by
something to do any other reasons people
might believe in God
this kind of interest because as our
culture we're very far removed from
where Thomas Aquinas was Thomas Aquinas
is not going to appeal to any of these
as a matter of fact he sees these as
reasons that you shouldn't trust it just
the mere fact that somebody taught you
to believe Thomas and say that's not a
good reason to believe in God think
about you what are you what are you
claiming you know that you know about
when you're talking about this god thing
you're talking about this thing that
created the universe and you know has
absolute power as omniscient super good
you know so good that he can bring good
out of evil you're going to say that you
believe in that because somebody just
told you that's the case wow that's not
rational Thomas would say wouldn't you
the gravitas and if you know stronger
grounds than just some of you told me
that because people tell you all sorts
of things I tonight I told my kids that
there's a monster that comes at night
and this is a very nice thing to do did
it it comes at night and steals naughty
children
ma you know they they they see through
that stuff fairly quickly but for the
whole how my daughter was convinced and
they actually went me ask some other
adults about that that's not a good
reason to believe in things personal
experience you see any problems with
personal experience just because you had
an experience of God does that mean that
I should trust them maybe there's
something wrong with your brain you got
hit in the head and so have bright light
through the workout out there is that a
reason why I should you know chain
the way I love not it might be a good
convincing reason for you but it's not
going to transfer to me I actually took
that Thomas it rejects this notion that
you didn't take the idea of God and
unpack it
so let's let's move on to that there's
another way of arguing for the existence
of God and that's looking at what we
call positive facts viewing what we call
metaphysics and why did none of you
suggest that as you know the obvious way
in which we should try to convince
somebody that God exists because we
don't do a lot of metaphysics in this
society doing we don't think about what
lies behind the appearances this is a
sort of foreign thing for us and we're
not actually going to look at all of
these five ways Thomas gives you five
ways arguing for God's existence before
we do that let's look at some of the
ground clearance in this this question
Thomas asks you Thomas asks us will
solve three things
in God's existence then he asks can it
be demonstrated or proven many finally
asks this got a good way to do things
isn't it
so just starting out with let's jump
right into whether God exists or not
maybe we should try to figure out
whether we can actually prove any of
this maybe we can't maybe some of the
religious people and also some of the
people who are atheists are right in
saying and you can't prove it one way or
another we should get this stuff out of
the way you know some people think that
God's existence is self evident that
it's just everybody should be able to
see this just like that
if they can't there's something wrong
with them they're dummies or they're
just perverse or something like that
Thomas doesn't think that's the case
here's some of the arguments that people
make in favor of that they say you know
those things can be said to be self
evidence the knowledge of which is
naturally implanted in us and you know
some people think that God is you know
put the knowledge of God into us as
human beings so we just have to think
about a little bit then we'll
automatically see it or feel it Thomas
says yeah sort of but it's awfully
confused and he gives this great example
if you see somebody coming towards you
at night you know somebody's coming
towards you you know that is not until
they actually get into the light
it's the same way with knowledge there
are some things that are self-evident to
us in a sense but they're not very
distinct and think about all the
different things people have said our
God over the course of time what are
some of the things people have worshiped
is God that you could think of
anything you remember maybe that maybe
guys didn't talk about this in history
classes or humanities classes or
literature classes do they not talk
about this anymore in school things that
people worship the too controversial the
data you know I wanted to I could I
could make my own church and I could say
we need to worship this loaf of bread
and if I set it long and hard enough
somebody come to believe it it wouldn't
make this God would it and what you
brought the bread no I wanted the bake
sale because I need some bread for
tonight it was fortuitous that they
happened to be up there and then
actually I thought ah she bought
cupcakes or something for you guys but I
didn't but you know most of your sick
Anglin so you wouldn't you wouldn't
really get that much of it that's how
I'm gonna consoled myself anyway Thomas
says okay yeah there's some sort of
natural idea in us but that's not enough
to go on and then you notice in the
second one what does he talk about well
you know some people say god is that dan
which nothing greater can be thought
where we heard that before
just last week same handsome right
Thomas is rejecting st. Anselm's
argument he's saying that st. Anselm is
saying all you got to do is think about
the idea of God you realize he has to
exist Thomas says that doesn't work
let's look at the next one some people
say that you can't prove one way or
another whether God exists and one of
the objections that I want to look at
really closely is this one they say it
seems that the existence of God cannot
be demonstrated for it's an article of
faith that God exists but what is a
faith cannot be demonstrated because a
demonstration produces scientific
knowledge whereas faith is of the
scene so there are some religious people
that would be very uncomfortable with
the notion that you could prove that God
exists because they say if you do that
you're taking away people's faith and
faith is something good right so if
you're taking away their faith because
faith and knowledge can't sort of faith
acknowledge can't be in the same thing
at the same time they're saying because
faith is believing in something that you
don't know and just believing in it and
knowledge is actually being able to to
give an account of it being able to
understand it I think you've probably
all encountered some some people whose
religious orientation is along these
lines right don't don't think about it
just believe if you do think about it
then sometimes they think that you're
not believing and you're not really a
good Christian or a good Muslim or good
can you pick whatever you want
Thomas rejects that Thomas thinks that
again faith and reason do in fact
overlap so he uses them both you might
say sort of like two horses that have
been paired together let's look at now
very quickly because we don't have that
much time that's in the class a few of
these five ways well actually before
that I'm going to look at one of the
objections because remember we talked
about problem with evil last last class
Thomas actually talks about this here
does God actually exist
one of the great arguments against God
existing is actually what we call the
problem of evil there's really only two
hardcore put up a lot of objection
arguments against God's existence and
somebody can say oh we know we don't see
God you know I
I'll see them down the hall or something
like that that's not really an argument
because God isn't the sort of thing you
when you know the owner of the eraser no
not there therefore he doesn't exist
that doesn't work there's two things
that are in a pretty good argument one
is called the argument from evil and it
works like this you say God is
omniscient right that's what we mean by
God God knows everything God is
all-powerful right again it's what we
mean by God God is Allgood yeah that's
something we mean by God so why is there
evil why are somebody's sick in class
today why do people kill each other over
terrible reasons why are there infants
who get cancer that's evil of one form
or another why does that exist
isn't that incompatible with this notion
of God and Thomas has one answer to this
in in here there there are many answers
that are given to this the answer that
he gives he's actually taken from
Augustine Augustine says since God is
the highest you wouldn't know a lot any
evil to exist in his works
lots of nipa tits and goodness we're
such as to bring good even out of evil
so being sick could be good because it
allows you to feel solidarity and
empathy with other people who are sick
and then to be a better person is that
what is that all of you who are sick are
going to do today exercising your
empathy maybe not
but he could be it's kind of hard to see
how this would work for some things like
a child get cancer or child being
terribly abused it's hard to see how
that way that that RV the argument that
Thomas is giving work for that but there
are other arguments I'm gonna give it
yeah does he believe in like the greater
Gillett of things like that something
things like not that I'm saying that any
notes good time enjoyed but like the
person that they have died and they're
like 5 years old or something with that
word below Jesus son well that would
work for some of them I suppose because
you know ami average some people turn
out good and some people yeah all right
but for anyone given what's a kid
against leukemia calm Sam he dies and
becomes five only God knows whether that
kid would have been good or evil and
there may be many Sam's who would have
been good and God allowed them to die of
natural causes when he could have done
in miracle Dippet n't so I don't think
that this argument we actually gets you
out of the problem of evil one that
Thomas is given there are other ones
we're not going to talk about them in
this class but if you're really
interesting that there's a philosophy of
religion press make up a little together
we'll talk on this next semester out the
other objection is you don't actually
need god of a picture to make things
make sense out of things he says it's
superfluous to suppose that what could
be accounted for by a few principles
that produced by many but it seems that
everything we see in the world can be
accounted for by other principles
supposing that God did not exist all
natural things can be reduced to one
principle nature right why does why does
this piece of chalk fall
gravity right gravity is part of nature
the way the world works why am i walking
across the room right now is anything
making me do that
remember when we talked about Aristotle
and talk about epictetus and freewill
I'm making myself move across the room
my will is doing it and so maybe just by
will and nature that's enough to explain
everything you know how to add in
evolution but what does evolution
evolution is just nature right we have
complicated theories but they all boil
down to nature physicists think that
there's four basic forces that govern
everything in the universe
they're always trying to figure out how
can you roll these into just one basic
force I'm not gonna try to remember than
1 p.m. because I Thomas says well
actually you can't explain everything
without bringing God is the picture this
is where Thomas's contributions kind of
interest Thomas will talk about the
observable world when you see smell here
which you observe right why do things
happen in the world as you know the
track that I dropped it broke and roll
away somewhere okay then help me yeah
okay so it had some sort of cause
actually a bunch of caused by gravity
here's a cause my letting it fall was a
cause I was keeping it suspended from
gravity if I take this desk
and it's just sitting there right now
and I push it over there I'm moving it
right that's changing when I take this
bread and I rip it in pieces or I slice
it I'm changing that bread then I'll be
changing it some more because I'm going
to be putting it into my mouth and
chewing on it and then swallowing it
provided nothing goes wrong right
oh thanks somehow something we already
happens I'm going to be changing this
bread
pretty soon into energy and then putting
it back into cells if I don't exercise
they'll get more fat cells that's energy
being stored so there's this world that
we observe and science talks about this
the world of change the world of causes
leading to the watts now can akua's
itself be an effect of something else
what do you think think about when
you're shooting pool any of you shoot
pool okay so you got a couple balls on
the table if you only have one ball left
on the table then either you won the
game or you lost the game the scratch on
the eight ball right
either way the game is over so long as
you're playing pool there's more than
one ball on the table and what are you
doing in pool I know you're shooting at
pockets that's your aim that's your tell
us your goal but what are you actually
doing physically
Boston should cool right what are you
doing what's it what's involved you know
there's balls cuz I heard and said that
yeah you hit one into another one yeah
what are you ready to get that ball with
I'm just like shoot it full sketch so
now think about that there's already a
complex system of clauses there why does
that let's say you're shooting the nine
ball in why is that nine ball go in the
pocket what got it moving the cue ball
that hit it does it say you're not doing
a complex shot alright we'll get that
cue ball the stick that you get what got
that stick moving you did you chose to
do that because you had some sort of
desire that desire moved you so you can
have a cause and had caught itself the
fact another cause and you can keep
going further and further back think
about you know when we talked about your
Assad alone efficient cause why are you
actually here there is there were I
guess we could say to efficient purposes
that that produced you what were they
did you have they have the same name
when your kids for all of you
yeah preparing spectrum own mom and dad
yeah
each contributed some genetic material
they came together and you didn't
miscarry in here you are there are
efficient causes of you how'd your
parents get here they just pop out of
the ground you've probably met the
people who made your parents your
grandparents grandparents right we can
keep tracing this all the way back if we
want to and you can say you know let's
say you believe in the biblical story
everybody came
and Eve you still have a problem right
where they come from and you can keep us
back further and further and further
further and you can do this with all
sorts of things you can do this with
efficient causality with motion you can
do this with why things are arranged the
way they are you know the Telos were the
design behind them but it always comes
back to the same thing can you go back
forever what do you think can you have
what they call an infinite regress so
there wouldn't be a starting clause
what would get things going the first
place
it can be a problem so if nothing got
anything going in the first place and
what's all this stuff that we're
observing right now what's you being
year and iPhones existing and which took
an awful lot of causes and effects
taking place and my existing how did all
this come to be if nothing ever got it
started that would be a problem with men
now some people will say stuff like well
the Big Bang you know it's the big name
by the way is a very recent scientific
theory for quite a long time scientists
I know the world was actually eternal it
didn't didn't begin in time and the Big
Bang was kind of revolutionary thing by
the way was a priest who came up with
that notion of Big Bang thinking in
terms of you know sort of the
transcendent God that caused everything
kind of liberate your mind to think in
these sort of terms you can also say you
know why are you man being the way they
are evolution why are those things the
way they are see what you're asking
about here is not just the phenomenon
you're asking about what we call
intelligibility the answer to the why
higher things the way they are what made
the Big Bang get started in the first
place
you could say it just happened just just
turned out that way is that a satisfying
answer what do you think we're you
satisfied to your kid and you'd ask your
parents why is this the way it is and
then you know you kind of bother them
for a while because they put up with you
and they'd say well you have to
understand this and this and this and
they say why is it that way and now
there's going to get a little irritated
well it's like this and this and this
why is it like that and finally
either one of two things they use a
shot-up if you had mean parents or they
said because if you had nice guys was
that satisfying just because this is
this is what Thomas is trying to get at
that if you don't have some sort of
cause that could actually get all of
this going you can't get the whole
project off the ground we know that the
whole project is off the ground because
we actually experience it so we're going
from the world of experience and we're
going back to what is let's say the
world of metaphysics and how are we
doing that we're reasoning and what is
this ultimately supposed to lead us back
to God you notice that he ends each one
of his argument for God's existence with
the same phrase he says it's necessary
to arrive at a first mover put in motion
by no other things that's everything
else going and this everyone understands
to be God and then you know the second
one he says it is necessary to have been
a first efficient cause to which ever
one gives the name of God we cannot to
postulate the existence of some being
having of itself it's own necessity and
not receiving it from another but rather
causing all causing and all others their
necessity this all men speak of as God
he keeps going on and on like this he's
sick this essentially metaphysical
concept this philosophical concept of
the first clause that got everything
going that's the same thing as Jews
Christians Muslims Hindus people who you
know talk about God mean when they use
that term now notice this is this is
pretty different that you know the guy
who
does this or that in the Bible this this
isn't necessarily a God it talks to
people you could actually be what we
call the Deus and not a Christian or not
a Muslim and believe in a God who gets
everything rolling and then just
relieves everything of all a lot of the
founding fathers in the United States
ran in fact what we call deus comes from
the word for God and they thought that
God gets the whole ball rolling and sets
everything up it's like a moral law in
us that we can discover and that leaves
everything to its own spices Thomas
himself didn't it Thomas has other
reasons for that but they're not is this
this question this article but we're
getting from this is a set of arguments
for why there has to be some sort of we
can call it a transcendent cause for
everything why does he have five
different arguments well there's at
least five different ways we can
understand this one is sort of like
billiard balls motion change another one
has to do with order in the universe
what we called an argument from his eye
if you look at I was just at the doctor
today and you look at those charts that
they have on the wall and you see how
complicated your knees are you know or
your backbone or you look at this on
your that must have taken some some
thinking how that ended up like that I
mean look at all these tendons and
ligaments they all got to be in just the
right place and they're actually set up
to compensate for each other so if one
of them gets screwed up the other one I
actually like takes up the slack you
know and think about this the stuff
you've made in your lifetime you know if
you've done any putting in a puttering
around Legos or tinker toys or stuff
like that how quick the stuff we broke
made wrong right
leggo car rolled it down bank broke into
a million pieces
your your knee is a lot more complicated
than that how did they end up like that
well you know one answer is evolution
all right it's better than our knees are
like this then we walk around if they
don't be like Apes you know watching
like this or something well you can keep
pushing these things back further and
further and further and I'm not actually
myself endorsing the argument from
design here as a philosopher I I
actually see something some trouble with
it myself but a lot of people think that
if you just look at physical phenomena
and look at the way the universe is
ordered it looks like things must have
been designed for a purpose like think
about your eyeball you ever looked at an
eye go to the optometrist you see all
the parts to the eye how did that come
together out of all the group that was
cells at one time awfully complicated
isn't it
you know Darwin himself when he wrote
about this he said yeah the eye I have
real trouble explaining that things like
you know birds beaks or you know our
fingers being the way they are even
emotions that stuff's pretty easy the
eyeball that's a tough one I have a real
hard time explaining how power got that
way kind of a camel leap of faith in
evolution well what's your experience of
things in the world when it comes to
causes and effects if there isn't a
designer for things but things usually
turn out very structured very orderly
very pattern even when you have a
designer these get screwed up right
forget who's in fashion here so throw
together a bunch of scraps of fabric
what are you doing but you wouldn't
really hit close yeah you there piles
one pile of things and let's say you
just sort of so damn at random that
maybe you get a quilt out of it but if
you want to make something like an
intellectual like let's say they'll just
think about this sweater I'm wearing
look pretty tricky pretty complicated
it's got quite a lot of machine
processes somebody actually had to
design this I'm pretty sure this didn't
didn't you know develop on the sweater
trigger something by itself the argument
from design works that way in thinking
about the world of phenomena that we
know could could you know your body
could this world that we experience have
turned out the way that it does without
some sort of intelligent force driving
it if you say no then you're a long
thing I want same lines as Thomas you
think there's something transcendent
designer maybe put the fabric of things
together the way the burden so we didn't
get very deep into Thomas's arguments I
actually have another video if you're
interested in my further with this I
have a video from the class that I
taught a while ago that I'll post for
you guys if you're interested in going
everything's you see the general idea
right this is very different than what
Ansel was doing
Ansel is working with the idea Thomas
looking out the world as trying to get
us back to what's behind what's what's
metaphysics lying behind the distances
and so see all of you next Monday